[Musique]
je vais vous donner mon nom dudit star
des années 2000 à vous de retrouver ce
qu'elle est devenue parmi les trois
propositions se rappeler de bi crawford
est atteint
g
m
[Musique]
alors qu'est devenu billy crawford est
ce qu il a une société de maintenance
informatique
est-ce qu'il coanime les philippines ont
un incroyable talent ou ce qu'il a songé
de sexe est devenu la mise en abyme
laurie exactement microphone on a un
visuel ou quelque chose billy crawford
on n'a même pas de visuel c'est très
bien produit
donc il co-anime les philippines ont un
incroyable talent donc voila merci on a
vidé ou à droite et à gauche de tous
qu'est devenu autiste du groupe linkup
alors linker vous rappeler c'était ça
on voit les changes
la gare de me demain pas d'où je viens
mais ces quatre et sur mon chemin
ouais d'ailleurs on n'aurait même pas
encore acquis sera avec nous mardi et
j'ai vu j'ai eu la chance d'y fière de
voir son clip ce qu'on était hier soir
ensemble avec matt
on a fait une petite sortie juste comme
ça pour recevoir tous les deux merci
d'éviter les fautes au sol eu la chance
de voir son nouveau clip et son nouveau
titre en exclusivité il venait de le
recevoir
ensemble ils soient elle a montré alors
très serré très fort il nous montrera en
exclusivité mardi dont tu te
reconnaîtras à notre invité ce matin les
séries donc otis du groupe linkup est ce
qu'elle est il devenu est-ce qu'il
répare des ascenseurs des caporal-chef
dans l'armée de l'air
ou est ce qu'il était et conseiller au
conseil régional d'île de france a
décroché les confier à sancerre télé
contrat il est telle et complète à la
dirai pas des verts s'appelle otis la
vallée blog c'est comme si je dis qu'est
devenu à kenda c'est ce que je fais des
glaces et celui de gauche oui et ça
c'est lionel quand même beaucoup et me
voilà alors série des télé conseillers
au conseil régional d'ile-de-france
aller qu'est devenu david charvet vous
rappelez d'elle
[Musique]
on se lasse d
la comac
à noter
what you
[Musique]
est ce là dessus
gestuelle
là
ouais gauche karim wade est ce que je
dois à ce que je dois peut-être revenir
un autre jour vous êtes occupé la
chanson y avait juste rendez vous chez
le médecin
je dois rester chaude allez je vous
laisse je reviens d'un autre jour mais
c'est prendre rendez vous avec j'étais
très ami avec david charvet
il m'avait sauvé dans une piscine
[Musique]
au ping
à 19 ans dans alerte à malibu jetez moi
oui bon voila si ce n'est pas ses choix
vous savez il avait été engagé à nice tu
es là je dis souvent dans la tamise où
je sais à malibu il avait enchaîné deux
lettres à moi si on commence à chypre
tu es devenu alors qu'est devenu le sien
il est agent immobilier à los angeles
oui oui les coachs sportifs à dubaï
comme pamela il est en couple avec adil
rami qu'on embrasse un immobilisme
agents immobiliers alors emmené maison
de fous il a au début ils vont demeurer
mais sans succès pendant que les maisons
écran 6 et des blindés
elle est fournie et l'hôtel autres
qu'elle a calé kaleka le dossier il est
blindé
je connais un petit peu la fin de l'été
des plateaux et david charvet à l'époque
sur mon nom c'est chrome était sympa il
est très sympa dali tiers est très sympa
alors les cherry qui est devenu mia frye
presse qu'elle travaille comme
photographe de mode rappelé le maire
fera les bons regarder la paille et
c'était sa manière tout d'abord c'est ce
que je veux qu'ils me tuent mais si tu
veux aller dormir moi je suis assise
iceq momcilo je t'écoute
tu sais que tu vas te donner des bonnes
vibes nom également
quelque chose de weeds ouais ouais ok
2012 chaud chaud frime sénat qui fixe
[Musique]
alors qu'est devenue la praille sk
travaille comme photographe de mode
est-ce que tu travailles à l'opéra de
paris où est ce que je vais faire un
lissage brésilien
[Musique]
l'opéra du tout regardé la réponse on la
réponse en images
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
merci au site
miam miam miam sera assis toi n'y a que
toi tu remets toi côtés de matthew
taylor maintien on se souvient de vous
en 2001 vous étiez membre du jury
chorégraphe dans popstars vous est ce
que vous vous rappelez merci ça va bien
c'est magnifique en tout cas ci a
franchement vous êtes très très belle
thank you thank you may as que vous
rappelez du rapid faith c'est ça c'est
vraiment quand j'ai envie que les gens
sourient sa souverain voilà donc ce qui
fait ses meilleures amies faye s'est
alors on parle on parle souvent de vos
expressions vous faisait exprès par les
implants français en anglais ou c'est
non c'est non vraiment c'est dans la
vraie vie je parle comme ça ouais bon
moi je suis américaine à la base donc
c'est mon français qui est très très bon
d'accord donc les gens glisse mais c'est
vrai que c'est que à l'antenne tous les
toutes les semaines que je voyais
effectivement né péripéties et que je me
rendais compte que je parlais autant
anglais et du franglais
mais je me rendais pas compte parce que
moi j'ai enseigne la danse au quotidien
et je fais ça pour en cours c'est vrai
les gens m'adorent joncour plein les
jambes de revient pour les parts de
skate et en même temps ils viennent je
pense pour le divertissement parce que
nos fans et c'est ça vous êtes en fait
les gens viennent pour le ce n'est pas
pour le state qui y viennent aussi parce
qu'elle est très symbolique dockett
she's so funny mia est ce que vous
feriez danse avec les stars
oui j'ai rencontré monsieur des
rennaises one maxime maxime à cannes
en mai et tout d'un coup une kia danse
avec moi danser avec moi je suis ok mais
je pensais qu'on allait danser genre hip
hop a juste pas un truc et vous n'étiez
pas sur la musique c'est du gros son
lourd
je crois que c'était en août un clin
donc vraiment je pensais qu'on avait
plein de hip hop nom et tout d'un coup
il me soulève une virevolte dans tous
les sens et là je fais cambrai pas tout
et j'étais avec une mini jupe there
magath mcaleese connaître les acquis
mais c'est la folie et il a vraiment une
je sais pas comment dire le efforts
c'est à dire que eelv a à z c'est à dire
il vous emmène dans une énergie en
prenant l'argent une façon de lui rendre
que honnêtement mais c'est vrai que même
à tuer quelqu'un qui n'est pas doué je
pense pas vraiment lee a mis à part il
paraît que vous avez une technique
infaillible pour voir si un gars sont
vraiment eux et performant oui voilà
avec les femmes
c'est vrai elle dit j'aimerais voir des
garçons danser ce soir et elle va dire
la mia est-ce qu'il faut danser seul ou
est ce qu'il faut dans sa compagne et
puisqu'il faut danser avec vous non mais
ça les pensées des dire que si c'est
éventuellement pour pouvoir
mon bilan c j'ai besoin de voir la
personne avant je vais pas perdre mon
temps est venu alors donc la personne
on va démarrer par j
gilles verdez calaisis alesi alors pas
précisées
il ya déjà un banquier comment vous le
chantez avant comme ça à balad pour moi
cette dynamique le quelques secondes
qu'il est arrivé je me dis oh ma garde
si il a l'air vraiment hommage aux
bâtiments à 12 mois gillot après midi
bah si mam était de musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils dansent pas comme ça on devrait bien
mieux est-ce que bien peu jugé et bien
moi honnêtement je me dis que j'ai
vraiment l'impression
parce que là tellement il a donné parce
que là l'essence et peut-être ambiance
et avec moi après oui oui oui
seriez vous ne le sentais pas du tout
d'accord non mais c'est pas ça j'ai pas
dit ça ça veut dire que j'ai tout la lui
apprendre
[Applaudissements]
comment
aulas
ga
mais quel regard jetez vous à l'eau et
les aînés du groupe
alors là honnêtement
ouais parce que moi je pensais que
c'était pas sûr regarde l'émission c'est
ma date il en parle beaucoup mais bon
tout ça je me suis dit mais peut-être
que c'est que wade n'a pas enterré
brasles nom de chez dior bail chez moi
je dirais que cet homme-là est un très
beau merci mais attention je confirme
savez vous de votre troisième à l'époque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'est ce qui lie la balade non
mais là vous avez il faut faire
attention c'est moi je ne peux pas faire
un replay oui parce que là un moment
donné là c'est un truc avec un doigté
extraordinaire dirais que oui mais
attention les mains quand même un moment
donné faire rêver
[Rires]
mais je m'appelle
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
et le feu mais une petite allumette
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
série 6 très bon chanteur et je vous
sais je venais très bon danseur
alors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis
bon
s'il vous plaît
m
[Applaudissements]
avec nous
ah oui c'est très bien de son sang il
faut faire un classement par exemple
deux des garçons qui viennent de dans ce
passé le dernier au premier en chacun a
sa personnalité je dirais que monsieur
il bouge il
il a besoin c'est à dire qu' il faudrait
qu'il ralentisse le canaliser parce que
sinon ça va aller très vite
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je les adore mais il a l'énergie et
l'alimentation
il a cette énergie fougue et le y est et
on va dire
le wave d'affaires en vie mais presque
alors après il y avait le banat monsieur
ah oui tu as christophe très suave c'est
déjà avant même qu'ils critiquent qui
viennent vous le mettriez donc devant
lui devant lui quand même d'accord maxi
maxi c'est s était très élégant et
d'énergie tout lui il irait il faut - il
fédère c'est une fée décentration un peu
l'étude c'est vrai il est concentré du
top 10 avec monsieur gilles on ne sait
pas à quoi s'attendre mais qui vive mais
ça peut aller très vite parler très vite
donc et maintient bien abattu vous avez
déjà avant on a déjà commandé des
acteurs crochus oui non mais c'est déjà
avant qu'il fasse quoi que ce soit il ya
une astuce il est beau il est beau il
est pas le signe donc ont déjà en devine
qui nous met en émoi
juste le regarder venir
je vais devoir partir
mais mon coeur n'est pas libre il est à
à droite oui mais amy absolue minea
après pour pour serrer vous avez valeur
alors serré c'est extraordinaire pour
tirer lui il a une variété marseille fra
ordinaire nous allons faire il est
international
oui ça c'est très beau on s'en doute il
s'achèvera à beaucoup une culture tu
sortais en tout cas quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]